foreign
Peace Garden Mama posts boundaries sound
like
I can help but I cannot do this for you
I am not responsible for your emotions I
respect your opinion but I have my own
opinion as well
I understand you're upset and I am not
okay with being spoken to that way
I am done talking about this
I need you to understand what I'm
feeling I don't need help problem
solving right now
right now I need some time to myself I
would love to hear more about this later
I understand I am important to you and
while I care about you I need some space
and the final boundary
no
now TK we'll put a link to that in the
show notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast if you want to read that tweet
or if you're watching the video version
on patreon Jordan has it up here on the
screen above our left shoulders here
pretty I love this with respect to to
boundaries because we often talk about
boundaries but what do those boundaries
look like now it's not about being no no
no no no no no we have to be careful of
that too right because it's easy to
become the vice president of no and this
is always no no we're shooting down
everyone's ideas in fact I had this
happen to me recently I was excited
about something when I came home and I
very rarely Ryan knows I've been excited
four times in my life
and so I come home and I'm excited about
something and uh I talked to Bex about
it and I could see the look of
trepidation on her face and
eventually we talked it through and she
got to a yes but there was a immediate
no up front based on her preconceived
notions or her own desires but also the
real problem was my expectation I walked
in there with I'm excited so you should
be excited too and so as soon as I saw
the no she didn't even have to say no I
saw it on her features right yeah and so
using no effectively is really important
it's like if you're if you're doing uh
Professor Sean does Jiu Jitsu right and
the key to jiu jitsu very rarely has to
do with like using all your muscle right
you don't it's not about overpowering
your opponent in fact it's often about
the opposite waiting till the right
moment to use your muscle but other
times you're actually using sort of
their Force against them in a way you
talk about that a bit
I mean basically just what you said um
but if
it's it's often an insult like um oh wow
if you if if you're sparring with
someone and they say oh wow you're
really strong they're insulting you
because you're you're you're showing
your strength you're showing your
strength you're not showing your
Technique yeah oh yes yeah I think
that's nice with the uh the ballingers I
see the the Tweet real quick you're
really strong right yeah
I appreciate that so there are a few of
these here that I think these are
helpful because it's framing it in the
affirmative right and people don't know
how to frame this yes like how often do
we get questions we're like oh I I got a
roommate or I got a family member or
whatever and like you know
um they asked me to constantly do things
and and we fight about it right yeah
it's like well you're framing it wrong
yeah as opposed to why are you fight
about it because often it's the no
immediately right as opposed to I
respect your opinion but I have my own
opinion as well that is a type of
boundary it's not saying your opinion's
wrong or I think you're wrong or you're
a bad person hey I understand we're both
on a different page and maybe you're
trying to convince me otherwise but I
have my own opinion about this I am not
responsible for your emotions and that's
not an affirmative but it is helping
them understand like okay I understand
that you're angry right now but you're
not angry because of me maybe you're
reacting to something I said or did but
I am not responsible for your emotions
and also I'm not responsible for what
improving your emotions changing your
emotions I can help but I cannot do this
for you what a beautiful boundary that
is these apply really well with children
right with Ella in her reading she'll
often ask well can't you just read it
for me
I can help but I can't read it for you I
can help but I can't do this for you AKA
I ain't the one
and then this one is great for
de-escalating I understand you're upset
and I am not okay with being spoken to
that way and I love the and as opposed
to the butt there right look I
understand you're upset
I'm not okay being spoken to that way
yeah it it's not the hey you're wrong
but I'm not okay with that yeah
why are you treating me that way right
why am I being treated like this right I
understand you're upset but it's not
okay to to talk to me this way I love
how all these boundaries are like I
don't know it's it's non-violent
communication yes it's putting the you
know something positive on the person
you're talking to and then the negative
piece of it or the feedback or whatever
you want to call it it's putting it back
on uh it's making it's taking ownership
right and uh yeah and what I just
realized too is maybe it's not positive
but it's neutral you know and that's
okay too yeah but as soon as you say
like you can't talk that way to me well
now
now you're putting that person on on on
the defense yeah and it's not even
whether it's positive or negative it's
affirming hey I understand that you're
upset that's affirming right yeah what
you're going through now at some point
you will put up that wall you can say no
or you can say I am done talking about
this because we're not getting anywhere
in fact we're getting farther away from
where we'd like to be so I'm done
talking about this right now yeah what's
key here is say no when you need to say
no but understand that the key to saying
no effectively is finding the way of
saying no that works for you because you
can say I'm not okay with being spoken
to that way and you can also say you
better watch who you talking to fool
both of those are boundaries one of
those might be more effective than the
other depending on where you are trying
to go and sometimes when I give tips for
people on how to say no or ways they can
word it there are always people that are
like
it's not that complicated I just look
people in the eye and I stare them down
and I say no and I dare them to talk
back to me but so many of us don't it's
so strong TK so many of us don't enjoy
that right so many of us struggle with
that and so understand that all of these
boundaries
there are ways you can put it across
that work for you it's like my mother
always tells me you know she'll say like
hey what's your thought on this and I'll
tell her and she's writing it down she's
like okay now you need to put it in a
way that Mama can say it baby and then I
say okay say it like this or sometimes
my wife will ask me about something and
I say oh just tell her say no girl I
can't do that my wife's like okay but I
don't talk talk like that can you give
me another way and I go oh yeah yeah
just say that doesn't work for me right
so it's exploring the way of saying it
that feels like it's genuine when it's
coming from you don't don't sound like
you're reading a script well I respect
what you are trying to communicate with
me sir uh it it does not you know it
does not land in the manner in which you
had to don't do that you sound like a
script you won't feel authentic and
they'll laugh at you
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free